so britain's roads are getting a big
injection of cash but do they really
need it well the imf has come up with a
way of measuring the quality of roads in
the most developed countries and this is
how they rated them you can see france
had the best roads italy over here had
the worst and the uk well not far off
the top has the second worst road
network in the g7 so there is room for
improvement but are we spending enough
well let's break down those numbers 15
billion pounds that's what's been
announced but that split over six years
up to 2021 which averages out at 2.5
billion pounds each year that's less
than a tenth of the total investment
budget of about 28 billion pounds a year
but there's still a big question over
whether that overall budget is enough
this chart shows you just how much the
government has spent on infrastructure
and investment and that includes new
roads as a proportion of total economic
output all the way back to the 1960s and
you can see how far it's fallen over
that period that's the the profile of uh
what's coming up after the awesome
statement but if more money is needed
there the question is where is it going
to come from back in march the
government expected the deficit this
year to be 87 billion pounds now in the
autumn statement this week the
expectation is going to be closer to 95
billion pounds so as someone once said
there's no money left which makes the
chancellor's job this week or the more
difficult